- Thanks to Skillshare for
keeping Legal Eagle in the air.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking the link in the description.
(laughing)
(optimistic music)
Hey, legal eagles.
It's time to think like a lawyer
or today it's time to laugh like a lawyer
because we're going to
have a change of pace,
and instead of destroying
your favorite childhood movie
or explaining why your
favorite legal drama
is completely full of holes,
Stella and I are going to
review some lawyer jokes.
They're gonna make fun of me.
Are you okay with that?
(dog barks)
So what I've done is I've asked a friend
to compile some lawyer jokes for me.
I haven't seen these ahead of time.
But let me know if you guys
like this change of format.
And I've done enough stuff about PewDewPie
to know that meme review is a thing,
so let me know if you want me to respond
to legal or law school memes.
I would love to make
this a continuing thing
because who are we if we
can't laugh at ourselves?
Let's see if this is clean.
(laughing)
Okay, but without further ado,
let's dig into the first lawyer jokes.
An attorney was working late one night
in his office when, suddenly,
Satan appeared before him.
The devil made him an offer,
"I will make it so you win every case
"that you try for the rest of your life.
"Your clients will worship
you, your colleagues will be
"in awe and you will make
an enormous amount of money,
"but in return you must give me your soul,
"your wife's soul, the
souls of your children,
"your parents, grandparents,
"and those of all of your friends."
The lawyer thought about it
for a moment and then asked,
"But what's the catch?"
(chuckling)
Oh god.
We might not have souls,
but we care about the
souls of the loved ones
that are in our lives.
Also, by the way, it
wouldn't be unusual for Satan
to Apparate in front of
us, that happens everyday.
What's the different between
a lawyer and a jellyfish?
One is a spineless, poisonous blob,
the other is a form of sea life.
(laughing)
God.
I would say that most of
the lawyers that I know
are actually very courageous
and are willing to work very,
very hard for their clients.
Why would a lawyer be spineless?
I mean, poisonous, okay sure.
A 50 year-old lawyer
who has been practicing
since he was 25 passed away and arrived
at the pearly gates for judgment.
The lawyer said to Saint Peter,
"There must be some mistake.
"I'm only 50 years old and
that's far too young to die."
Saint Peter frowned
and consulted his book,
"That's funny.
"When we added up all
your billing records,
"you should be at least 83 by now."
(laughing)
I like that one.
This one hits close to home
because there are some lawyers out there
who are unethical and they will bill
their client for more work
than they've actually done
and this is reasonably ethical
where you're on a plane
and because of the shift in timezones,
you're actually able to
build more than 24 hours
in the entire day
if you were literally working
every single hour of the day.
So you were up all night,
you did an all-nighter
and then you flew backwards
from the east coast to west coast.
It is conceivably possible
and there are some rockstar
associates who have been known to do that,
but yeah, fair point.
Oh god.
Let's see if this is clean.
Why does the Bar Association
Code of Ethics prevent
sex between lawyers and their clients?
To prevent clients from being billed twice
for essentially the same service.
Hopefully you have a better experience
than, we'll say, getting
screwed by your attorney.
Actually California just
changed their ethics rules.
It used to be that in
California you could engage
in a romantic relationship
with your client
and now, at least during the
pendency of your relationship
is unethical in California
to have that relationship
with your client.
So, realistically speaking,
you can get in big trouble in California.
Yeah, that's a big change.
At a convention of biological scientists,
one researcher remarks to another,
"Did you know that in our lab
"we have switched from mice to
lawyers for our experiments?"
"Really?" the other replied.
"Why did you switch?"
"Well, for three reasons."
"First we found that lawyers
are far more plentiful.
"Second, the lab assistants
don't get so attached to them,
"and thirdly there some
things even a rat won't do."
(laughing)
Oh god.
But, frankly, if you hire
a lawyer and you need them
to help you on your case,
you're gonna want them
to be flexible and to
be a zealous advocate
and to really get in the trenches
with the rest of the rats, oh my god.
Lawyers are far more
expensive than rats, though.
Why did New Jersey get all the toxic waste
and California get all the lawyers?
New Jersey got first pick.
All right, fair enough.
The California legal market is huge.
That's where I have practiced
for most of my career.
Frankly, I prefer
California than New Jersey.
So suck it, New Jersey.
Two physicians boarded
a flight out of Seattle.
One sat in the window seat,
the other sat in the middle seat.
Just before takeoff, an attorney got on
and took the aisle seat
next to the two physicians.
The attorney kicked off his shoes,
wiggled his toes and was
setting in when the physician
in the window seat said,
"I think I'll get up and get a coke."
"No problem", said the attorney.
"I'll get it for you."
When he was done one of
the physicians picked up
the attorney's shoe and spat in it.
When he returned with the
coke, the physician said,
"That looks good, I
think I'll have one too."
Again, the attorney
obligingly went to fetch it
and while he was gone,
the other physician picked up
the other shoe and spat in it.
The attorney returned
and they all sat back
and enjoyed the flight.
As the plane was landing,
the attorney slipped
his feet into his shoes
and knew immediately what had happened.
"How long must this go on?" he asked.
"This fighting between our professions,
"this hatred, this animosity,
"this spitting in shoes
and pissing in cokes?"
(laughing)
So I have a lot of doctor friends.
I don't think there's
much animosity between
lawyers and doctors.
Really it's just between
me and Doctor Mike
because we've never done a collaboration.
You know what you've done, Doctor Mike.
- Dude, you're hilarious and if you ever
wanna make a YouTube video, I'm so down.
- A lawyer was filling
out a job application
when he came to the question
have you ever been arrested?
He answered no.
Next question, intended for applications
who had answered yes was why?
The lawyer answered
it, "Never got caught."
(laughing)
So the thing is it's
really the rare exception
that it's like a Bernie Madoff
or some other corporate raider
who has done some illegal act.
That and the doctors,
they're the real criminals.
♪ Bye, bye, bye ♪
- C'mon, son!
- A secretary, a paralegal, and a partner
in a city law firm are
walking through a park
on their way to lunch when
they find an antique oil lamp.
They rub it and a genie
appears out of a puff of smoke.
The genie says, "I only
grant three wishes,
"so I'll give each of you just one."
"Me first, me first," says the secretary.
"I want to be in the
Bahamas driving a speedboat
"without a care in the world."
Poof, she's gone.
"Me next, me next," says the paralegal.
"I want to be in Hawaii
relaxing on the beach
"with my personal masseuse
and an endless supply
"of pina coladas and the love of my life."
Poof, he's gone.
"You're next." The genie
says to the partner.
The partner says, "I want those two back
"in the office after lunch."
(laughing)
There's definitely some truth to that.
I have had some great luck in my career
to have some fantastic legal
secretaries and paralegals
in my office and they have saved my bacon
on more than one occasion.
Man, you're not getting away that easily.
All right, let's see, this
one is in the first person.
I was in juvenile court
prosecuting a teen suspected
of burglary when the judge
asked everyone to stand
and state his or her name and
role for the court reporter.
"Leah Rauch, deputy prosecutor," I said.
"Linda Jones, probation officer."
'Sam Clark, public defender."
"John," said the teen who was on trial.
"I'm the one who stole the truck.
(laughing)
Okay, yeah.
(exhales)
That one hits close to home.
If only I could control
what my clients said
at all times because they have a habit
of saying the worst possible thing
at the worst possible time.
It's a mark of a good lawyer
when you can control a very bad witness.
When my 88 year-old mother was called
for jury duty she had to submit
to questioning by the opposing lawyers.
That's called voir dire.
"Have you ever dealt with an attorney?"
Asked the plaintiff's lawyer.
"Yes, I had an attorney
write my living trust,"
she responded.
"How did that turn out?"
"I don't know," she said.
"Ask me when I'm dead.
(laughing)
Ah, some good old fashioned
the states and trusts humor.
That's always great.
All right last one, here we go.
What's the difference
between a good lawyer and a bad lawyer?
A bad lawyer might let a case
drag on for several years.
A good lawyer knows how to
make it last even longer.
Too mean, too mean.
Oh, where those good?
Where those good lawyer jokes?
All right, those jokes were terrible
and you are a bad person
if you laughed at them.
Completely unfunny and
not a kernel of truth
in the whole lot of them,
but if you wanna learn how
to write hit online content
that makes people laugh and
share, not like those jokes,
then you should definitely check out
Matt Bellassai's Skillshare
class called Going Viral.
Write, film, and make
content people share.
Matt teaches you how to write comedy gold
and create viral content
that people love to share.
The writers of those jokes
really should of taken
his class because all of
those jokes were not funny.
Matt's lessons are packed with tips
about originality,
developing your comedy voice,
tweeting better tweets,
creating better videos
and writing headlines that will grab you
like Unfunny People Write
Bad Jokes About Lawyers.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has over 30,000 classes on everything
like lifestyle, design, and technology.
The first 500 legal eagles
will get two free months
of Skillshare when you
click on the link below,
plus it really helps out this channel.
The free premium membership gives
you unlimited access to must-know topics
so you can improve your
skills and learn new things,
all free for two months.
Improve yourself now so
you can write good jokes
which won't involve lawyers
because lawyers are above comedy.
So click on the link below,
get two free months of Skillshare
and start learning to
think like a lawyer today.
All right so, as always,
leave your objections
in the comments and send me
your memes and lawyer jokes.
I would love to do this again,
and check out my other real
law reactions over here
where I just reacted
to Marvel's Daredevil,
including the trial of Frank Castle.
So click on this playlist,
and I'll see you in court.